See,
in the Soviet Union when soldier knits
and wrote about the Soviet Union and its
pathologies,
it,
it sort of peaked in terms of it's
pathological authoritarianism when it
became illegal to complain that your
life wasn't going well and you just
think about how horrible that is say
because,
because you know,
lots of times your life isn't going
well.
I mean,
and I don't mean this in some casual
way.
I mean maybe,
I don't know.
Maybe you have diabetes in your year and
Oh,
maybe you're gonna lose your feet or
something.
It's really not.
It's nothing trivial that's going on
here.
Something is not good or maybe it's
economic or maybe you're unemployed or,
and,
but you see the idea and the Soviet
Union was,
well,
we already have all the answers.
Everything is perfect already.
That's what totalitarians think.
Well,
if everything's perfect and you're
suffering,
then well,
maybe there's something wrong with you
because everything is perfect after all.
And if you're suffering,
then what are you gonna come out and
say,
well,
I'm suffering.
It's like,
well then your evidence that things
aren't perfect,
right?
You're like a widow or an orphan in an
old testament story,
you know when the Kings got too high and
mighty,
then they wouldn't pay enough attention
to the widows and the orphans and then
the profit would come along and say,
you know those widows and orphans a lot
more important than you think they are,
and if you don't pay attention to them
property,
then things are going to fall apart
around you in a way that you just can't
even imagine and so well then you're
sort of like your own widow in your own
orphan,
but you don't get to say,
Hey,
look,
you know things aren't perfect yet
because I'm actually having still quite
a rough time here.
You don't get to admit to your own
suffering.
If you can't admit to your own
suffering,
then you certainly see the suffering,
especially the additional suffering.
The excess suffering should be treated
as evidence that you're not doing
something quite right yet.
It should be treated as evidence that
you're wrong.
There's something important that you're
doing that's wrong.
I understand how harsh that is and I'm
not saying that everyone who is
suffering is suffering because they're
doing something in some simple way
that's wrong.
I was in an elevator once in a hospital.
It was a very terrifying thing and this
person got on who was just in an
absolute state of shock,
you know,
I mean,
it was really not good and I don't
remember how this happened,
but I engaged the person in conversation
and they just said that they had just
been diagnosed with what looked to be
terminal cancer.
And uh,
what was horrifying about it was that
what they were doing was going over
their life in the elevator trying to
figure out what they had done in order
to deserve such a fate.
You know,
they immediately taken it on themselves
as a moral failing.
And that's not what I'm saying.
You can't come up to someone who has
cancer and say,
well,
if you weren't such a bloody idiot
throughout your whole life,
you wouldn't have cancer.
And believe me,
that happens a lot more than you think.
And people who have diseases like that
get blamed for it.
That's not what I'm saying.
It's not like it's,
it's,
it's a more generalized attitude.
That is that if life isn't yet what it
should be,
then you have a response.
You have a primary responsibility to do
something about it and the place to
start looking is to your own errors and
to fix them.
And that's.
And that's,
that's,
that's a safe bet,
man,
because you're probably doing some
things that you would,
wouldn't have to be doing that if you
fixed would make things better.
So it's time to let go and to sacrifice
who you are for who you could become.